we got the story from scanner cnr.com
Rumble files lawsuit against media
Watchdog group when anti-free speech
zealots lie to inflict intentional
economic harm on our company we have no
choice but to hold them accountable
video streaming platform Rumble has
filed a federal defamation suit against
two co-founders of a media Watchdog
group I don't think it's fair to call
them a media Watchdog group that's their
language who wrote this story chis this
is Chris burtman Chris Burman you see
he's he's doing the right thing in
trying to be honest and fair in labeling
the group what you would assume them to
be if you understand what this group
does I would not call them a media
Watchdog group I wouldn't either yeah
lying about uh people and trying to
engage in torous interference is not
media Watchdog it's it's it's it's you
maybe maybe uh
leftist or liberal political activism is
probably fair to say but uh just just
real quick to get to the opening context
here Rumble is uh suing these
individuals because they claimed that
Rumble uh receives 90% of its funding
through Google ads or something to that
effect and that's not true Rumble says
this is completely false and they
actually told them this is not true and
it's damaging to to their brand because
Rumble they businesses we are
independent from Big Tech so they said
they know it's not true they won't take
it down we're suing them for defamation
which means either these people
knowingly uh uh knowingly posted lies
and considering they've been informed
it's not true that it seems that may be
the case or theyve just Reckless
disregard for the truth but these groups
uh these individuals have gone after
Steve Bannon Charlie Kirk I'm pretty
sure uh they go after you right jack
well they go after post millennial human
events they sure do but don't do they
have you listed as their their
insurrectionists I'm on the list uh I'd
have to look let me they came after us
because of our work with with Andy and
they it's usually about Andy oh yeah
they worked with they basically like got
antifa to go after our advertisers and
take you didn't make the list sorry
sorry Jack it's a Dan banino Charlie
Kirk Tucker Carlson uh we got Glenn
backck Ste uh uh uh Bannon Steve Bannon
and me I reached out at one point I
don't even know why I'm on there wait
scroll down a little bit it's is just
it's wild what are you looking for well
because it's talking about the January
5th show of war room cuz I was sitting
next to Steve on the show but yeah
didn't make the cut cut make C I on this
list they claim I will try harder during
the next Insurrection I promise they
they argue that I'm one of the biggest
proponents of the big lie and the big
lie is defined as Donald Trump claiming
he actually won 2020 and I've always
maintained that never heard you say that
I I I I argued with banon that I that
know twice so uh like you guys went at
it in the third hour too yeah my my
position was like dude people keep
saying Biden can't get 85 million votes
and I'm like you're correct Trump got
anti vote like people weren't voting for
Biden don't don't think that but I I I
think what we saw was proced there issue
with those ballots I don't know about
that what I what I what I what I will
what I will say is if if you operate
under the assumption that fraud is the
reason you lost you lose again if you
operate under the assumption that
Democrats were changing rules in ways
that greatly benefited them and they did
you will you will win for one we we saw
in Georgia uh uh Republicans lost the
senate race because there are people who
are like what's the point of voting
anyway they're going to steal it no no
we can't have that mentality but anyway
without getting into all that stuff
because we don't need to the fact that
they are arguing I made these claims now
I you you totally get why why they're
being sued by Rumble okay this is not a
media Watchdog group they're outright
lying I actually reached out to one of
the board members in 2021 when they were
uh targeting post-millennial and we were
losing ad revenue and it was uh it was
not a pleasant moment you actually lost
ad Revenue yeah because of them yeah how
uh because they went after our
advertisers and our advertisers refused
to advertise on the platform wow because
if an Advertiser sees this is valid they
present themselves I asked them about it
I asked one of the board members about
it directly and she responded and she
said as um she said uh as to advertisers
being intimidated into dropping you
advertisers are not so easily scared if
they drop you it seems worthwhile to
look at why and make your choices about
what or what not to do about it
um and she later said uh you know keep
your eye on the prize what is so
important is to consider why would an
Advertiser drop a publisher they think
worthy of support they wouldn't so she
ended up saying you know basically that
Publishers make these decisions and the
people who um where they advertise like
post-millennial should make different
decisions in order to keep the
advertisers yeah so it is an
intimidation thing for sure I mean it
they admitted it and they also said in
part that their goal is to destroy the
adte business entirely yeah I mean if
they are not open about what their
political leadings are then or even if
they are they can still be accepted as a
as a mainstream reference right you'll
have things all the times that are say
oh you're on the splc's list of whatever
and so we can't trust your opinion
you're on this group's thing so we can't
advertise with you these lists are
created so that they become taken as you
know as gospel goel never trust any you
know conservative that doesn't get ended
up on one of these lists or doesn't get
attacked by any of these people ever
trust them I want to pull up uh this
post from them so you can understand
this is what Rumble is suing they
tweeted in case you're wondering where
Tim pool's Bean right-wing podcaster Tim
Pool isn't selling ads anymore after a
successful check my ads campaign he's
selling dot dot dot coffee and we found
out who makes the beans uh here's the
thing we we we are we are selling ads we
have we've never lost a sponsor uh we
have all our sponsors still we I we
literally just recorded several ads what
on on what day is it Wednesday on Monday
on Monday I'm like everyone get out
we're recording ads for the same
sponsors we just finalized another sixf
figure sponsorship deal they're outright
lying and using the lies to make money
to convince people to donate wait so cuz
I I remember seeing that when when they
posted that or or you know you were
tweeting at them or something and then I
would went back and was thinking like so
sometimes if I don't catch the show live
I'll go back and listen on the podcast
side and I'm like they're all there like
you you can hear it it's totally normal
and it's been that way for I don't know
years at this point so we've been doing
mostly over the past few months direct
reads for uh cast Brew Coffee obviously
because we're building up our own
company which is probably going to crack
over a million dollars in revenue
revenue in its first year so in in in a
conspiracy to profit you've created a
company and you're using your other
company to leverage that new company I
mean this is this is this is the most
nefarious thing I've ever heard So
currently we have uh our same ad sales
rep for we used we used to do more live
reads during the show now it's all just
the recorded right so if you guys listen
on this on the podcast you'll get the
recorded ads where it's like that's what
I'm saying better help and and and the
sponsors are all still there and we
actually do really well we like
substantially they are outright
fabricating this and I I will add the
only reason we did not we we've not done
live reads specifically despite the fact
we still have all these sponsors asking
us when we will is because we're trying
to promote as much as possible caspr but
we actually did a deal for some live
reads on the show again like what you
see what they deceptive language first
of all they said I'm not selling ads
anymore totally false we're absolutely
selling ads we still have all the same
sponsors and we just finalized a six
figure deal with a new sponsor mhm so
that is factually incorrect is it is it
is absolutely false and they say after a
successful check my ads
campaign is that fraud they're fising
about this I it doesn't make sense to me
also because I mean did they did they
get in contact like where did they find
out that you weren't selling ads
obviously if they had done any kind of
research that would have been false they
they contact our ad sales they sort of
were like oh Tim's not talking about
something so we've decid like it doesn't
make any sense but if if you listen they
take donations so there's T3 yes if you
listen to the audio podcast there's I
think 10
ads like from a ton of different
sponsors a lot and they're fundraising
off the LI that we some of it's inserts
some of it's like donuts some all
different things it seems weird it's
style of B folks he's not actually
advertising Donuts it's when they send
you part what that's when you like when
they send you part of an ad and then you
insert something and then you know yeah
so here's here's the way it works uh
some ad sales are like hey we have an ad
we want to run it on your show it's like
all right great we have an ad we have an
ad company that we have an management
company that handles that we just choose
where in the show to put it and then a
few of our sponsors our bigger sponsors
they say we want Tim Po to read this
personally correct we say you got it and
that costs obviously a little bit more
and then for this show we actually have
all of our sponsors we used to do reads
for like virtual Shield there's um
safeand ready meals.com there's uh what
else do we have um the like protein
energy thing oh right we got the
collagen we have we have the we have the
the the camping gear and stuff
yeah all of these sponsors are still
there and and i' we we've actually been
I've been I've been talking with the ad
sales guy about end of the year sales to
pick back to bring them back in because
I'm like look we've been doing Casper
this whole time anyway I digress I
digress yeah because usually my
contracts run like like to it's like
January to January so so at this point
we do monthly we're going into really
yeah every month we renegotiate and that
I I like it better because I'm like look
you know we had a great month this
month's going to be bigger we want more
money yeah so well I shouldn't say all
most my my ad guy just sent me like a
December pitch and I said yes and
they're like this is insane it's just
absolutely insane that these groups lie
look I guess they have success in some
areas like you guys were losing money
I'm like what are they talking about I
never promoted the big lie I never
claimed Trump won and we we still sell
ads yeah jooe this is wild I I I don't
know man like do do I have to pursue
some kind of like criminal charge like
fraud charges against because it I guess
what you'd have to do is find someone
who donated to them because they
believed this organization had
negatively impacted our business they
also have a tweet up claiming that our
website's demonetized which it's
literally nut it's
crazy you know man whatever though but
rumble's suing them because they're
doing the same thing they claim that
Rumble is operating off Google ads and
and rumble's like no we aren't in fact I
I will I will add uh well I shouldn't
say too much but uh what I can say is
Rumble has has their own ads that appear
on Rumble wild this is this this is what
these activists do they claim to be an
organization that fights disinformation
but literally all they do is manufacture
it also they're a not for profit their
their 501c3 status is pending and I just
wonder what is so charitable about this
organization that tax dollars should be
going to this group right I mean why is
the IR do don't go to it they just don't
pay tax they just don't pay taxes on it
exactly they're just claiming that
they're doing a public service by you
know telling you what's going on and the
public has more information this way you
know they'll get their 501c3 status
because ultimately the people who give
to them are the same people who give to
the political leaders who are in charge
right now I mean they they see it as a
benefit to their own mission and that's
why they can send you at emails being
like well if you were better at
publishing better stuff then your
advertisers wouldn't pull out it's not
that we bullied them it's just we
decided that you were an unwanted
organization and told them that it's
crazy it feels very dystopian to me like
listen grants and individ and and
individual
donations the company does interesting
yeah so I'm looking up their uh their
filings that was the weird thing about
hearing Elon Musk talk which is that
he's saying you know the advertisers
believe they can ultimately get me to do
what they want even even so we're going
to opening up with well you're sort of
on this apology tour and I felt like I
could watch Elon Musk tense and be like
I'm absolutely not an apology tour I am
not going to admit that you guys or or
uh admit wrongdoing admit wrongdoing or
just partake in this in this
manipulation of what you want and I
think the weird thing is that ultimately
advertisers need the eyes and the eyes
are going to stay on Twitter meaning
that the users are staying on Twitter
even if the advertisers pull off right
like the engagement on Twitter didn't
dip because the advertisements went away
ultimately to me it seems like someone
else will rise up and take those spots
back or they'll come back because that's
where the crowd
is wild yeah it's it's it's it this is
what we're up against well and Texas is
is a the Texas AG is suing Media Matters
you he is suing he investigating he was
investig he's investigating Media
Matters so in Texas they can't bring
it's their AG is situated a little bit
differently like he has to pass off a
criminal case to someone else they can't
bring them themselves like they can you
can in some states um same with civil
and so Missouri was a huge one because
they able to bring direct action um but
it's it's just a great example right so
look at the Trump cases that are going
on right now from the left um you've got
the Attorney General of New York finding
any pretext to go after him literally
any pretext to go after him his company
his family even things that didn't even
happen in her State she's finding a way
to make it happen uh you see this with
Fanny Willis you see this again and
again the one of the best from his
perspective one of the most strategic uh
and most efficient uses of money that
George Soros ever did was in funding all
of these people because for couple
million bucks here and there you compare
that to like the coke industry uh the
coch brothers who spent billions like uh
just just Dr drowning our country down
the tubes and now they want to throw all
this money behind nck they're backing
Haley crazy and you compare that to just
a couple of million bucks that George
Soro spent in key targeted races whereby
in he's now able to have the president
of the United States arrested uh he's
able to have the front runner for the
Republican nomination be put under a
series of Trials so all of this is going
on meanwhile Republicans will sit back
and go oh we can't do anything like that
that's not fair you know you've got all
of these organizations look what they
did to the NRA look what Laticia James
did to the NRA and just completely
castrated them in front of everyone sure
they still exist on paper but there's so
much more castrated than they've ever
been in terms of the 2A fight right now
at a time where you know just to be
frank about it you know the Republican
party needs single issue voters look at
how the Democrats are utilizing
single-issue voters when it comes to
abortion and turning that into a massive
ballot harvesting operation the NRA
could be doing that if they existed or
had any any serious operations right now
just doesn't EXA after what latia James
did and Republicans will sit there and
say oh that's not fair meanwhile
Democrats are saying let's strip Trump
off the ballot let's find any way that
we can destroy you guys and keep
pressing the advantage because again
Democrats know how to use government
power they will use government power and
Republicans are terrified so I threw out
there and not to get into like the
primary stuff unless you want to um or
about to actually okay well I was G I
threw out there that that a guy like
Ronda santis would never even like he
would be physically terrified to utter
the words I'm going to have Joe Biden
stripped from the ballot in Florida Y
and you know he has full power in the
state super legislature you know he
could easily file a charge from his
campaign saying that Biden is ineligible
and you find pretext under the fact that
he that he took bribery from China which
is an impeachable offense and he could
say therefore you are not eligible to
run for president under the Constitution
and you could file that lawsuit and this
guy he would be terrified to do that
because and you can say it's not the
stones not the backbone whatever it's
just no he he's a pedantic rule follower
he's terrified of actually standing up
for himself and fighting back and it's
why like he'll go on La Ingram and can't
even you know can't even name r McDaniel
and say oh I'm you know terrified to do
this you can see Lara like rolling her
eyes at him and my my point is that it's
it's not even an anti- deanis thing it's
just that there's a lot of Republicans
like this they are terrified to actually
use government power well let's jump to
this story from the Daily Mail you know
what this means exclusive US military is
seeing UFOs in space official report
says and that can only mean one thing
Hunter Biden was caught with weird money
laundering again Fox news reports moneya
laundering investigator warned of Hunter
Biden's unusual erratic payments from
China in 2018 the bank investigator
raised concerns about money that
ultimately funded the $40,000 payment to
Joe Biden comr says so uh of course
there's a big UFO Story coming out
coming out on the same day that there is
a mysterious Chinese payment to Hunter
Biden in the news surprise surprise and
uh looks like Fox news's website is
completely broken the best part about
this story was that the uh the people
who the bankers that flagged the
payments said that there was um no
obvious services rendered yeah I love
that who knows what are they pay do you
think the UFO people are sad that the
thing they love and are passion about
has been ruined by the Biden
Administration I think they must be
right I think they're just stoked that
people are talking about no hold on hold
on hold on there was a t no no the UFO
people turned on Fox News and they
reported Hunter Biden and they
immediately called their friends we got
UFO news coming you're like brace
yourselves it's about to happen maybe
that's good bid in the news cuz I was
thinking if you're a UFO person you're
like the the Biden Administration is
just releasing all kinds of fake
information under the guise of UFOs to
distract from Hunter but maybe the the
information they're releasing is
legitimate and that way you can really
distract people you know what I mean
like are they making stuff up to cover
up Hunter crime they're stretching
nonsense they have these minor reports
where it's like a guy saw a thing who
knows and now they're like look over
here thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 P.M
and become a member over at timcast.net